[Music]
it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the stars are posting
online Celine Dion is getting back to
her lighter locks check out the singers
nearly platinum you do how long have you
two been together
oh we're not for sex friends yeah
Natalie Portman recently claimed Ashton
Kutcher was paid three times what she
made for no strings attached now the
actor is backing her up on Twitter
praising her for speaking out there's
some things that just aren't cool and I
don't think this is very cool
kendall Jenner isn't cool with internet
rumors the model vented her frustration
on her website refuting any speculation
that she had facial reconstructive
surgery Joseph Fiennes portrayal of the
King of Pop in an upcoming TV show has
his daughter Paris pretty peeved the 18
year old tweeted she's incredibly
offended and added it honestly makes me
want to vomit we can't not Billie lourd
paid tribute to her late mother Carrie
Fisher on Instagram posting this sweet
throwback with a touching caption
finding the funny might take a while but
I learned from the best and her voice
will forever be in my head and in my
heart
[Music]
you